do you think it's possible to make a to
teach machines not just how to learn but
how to feel
i think there's a lot of uncertainty
about
the philosophy of mind question about
what the criteria are for say being
sentient for having conscious
experiences it's
something philosophers uh have wrestled
with for
for a long time
and i do believe that we will eventually
have
machines digital minds
that are conscious
and that then will also have moral
status and that means that
the question is not just what do they do
to us or what do we do to each other
with machine tools but also what do we
do to them um so the ethics of digital
minds i think
will gradually arise as a really
important issue
today it's a little bit outside the
overtone window it's a kind of whacky
thing that you can't really but but
i think the time has come now where at
least some people have the luxury to be
like you know in academia sitting and
thinking about things
all day long uh when we should start to
try to work out some of what this might
look like a world where say humans and
ais have different levels of capability
and at different levels of sentience
have to co-exist in some kind of
workable harmony
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]